but see this is
chicken with a taste howdy bees is just
hot i told you dude
this is amazing this is the best chicken
sandwich in the world
and you haven't had carbs in 19 years
no dude get you isn't it good shout out
to cat forget it
here's my thing i'm gonna eat it after
it's gonna be my late lunch
because i did food truck diaries with
cheeto vera before this and we had
you know i i can't be on a diet and do a
food truck show
so i gotta eat with the guests i used to
be on a diet and not eat and people like
do what the [ __ ] can't do it
so i eat with the gas now it was uh you
know i don't pick the trucks the
mauka uh production sets it up and it
was a
macaroni and cheese truck you know so
you have macaroni and cheese and they
toss all the [ __ ] on it
dude you know i've been doing food
trucks for about two years now we've had
a
million guests on there it's my f i've
had my
it's top three for me the mac and cheese
no
the the the fighter cheeto i don't know
if you know cheetah just being
sugar shawn o'malley he's been fighting
uh he's had 15 fights in the ufc he's
been fighting for a long time
and he's just been grinding and finally
he's getting the notoriety that you know
he deserves
and he comes from ecuador and going to
this story where he came from ecuador
and his
daughter was born with a condition where
she doesn't she the muscles wouldn't she
couldn't smile
she had no facial expressions so this
dude i i was getting choked up he's
talking about he goes
so my goal was to make enough money to
pay for the surgery so she could smile
because i didn't want to get made fun of
in school oh my god oh my god so he
meets with a doctor in beverly hills
they asked for
80 80 grand he's like well i got to make
80 grand
so he starts to go fund me he gets you
know 60 grand on his own
and then the doctor's like yeah i'll do
it for that money so he got it done
that is so amazing got it done dude
one of my favorite people just so he can
see his daughter smile now
yeah she can smile she has facial
expressions and he talks about how he
came from ecuador at 19
and she had this issue and he's like we
got like the state to be able to figure
this out makes enough money
fighting with his [ __ ] hands to pay
for his daughter's surgery
that's why man you know listen like you
cannot
not watch that food truck diary and not
be like oh i'm a cheeto
fan like you're gonna watch this like oh
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] with cheeto vera dude
this is why
when when i hear people and i don't mean
to
and i'm not a political dude right but i
would
i would die for my kid right 100
so when i hear people say when people
travel
walk or whatever in caravans from
central america to get to the united
states
those are not the bad guys they are
trying to save their families like
i'm a hundred percent i would walk
wherever
if you're telling me your kid's gonna
die here and they could live a better
life there i'm like well where's there
yeah i'm gonna swim from from [ __ ]
cuba to florida
i'm gonna take my chances 100 100 i do
have a question about fighting though in
general
it seems like and i could be 100 wrong
and a lot of times
dude it seems like especially lately
especially except
you know with the daniel cormier but
more of the compelling fights in boxing
and ufc is in that weight class of
somewhere between 140 and one
why is that is that just because the
athletes are there well the yeah because
think about it if you're
you know it's always been notoriously
been this way in fighting if you're a
bigger athlete let's say
let's say you're my size you're 6'4 240.
you when you're a kid your dreams not to
be a fighter
your dreams to be a baseball player
football player basketball player right
but those
you know if you're born and you're five
seven hundred and sixty pounds
you're not going the nba you're right in
the nfl you know you're not doing
anything but you can
wrestle and do jiu jitsu and learn how
to fight
so the roster at 155 in the ufc and
bellatoran
championship the lighter weights it's
the talent pool there is so deep
because there's so much more to pick
from there's so much more competition
there that makes and the talent is so
much higher
because like the number one guy at 55
hit skill wise compared to the guy at
you know heavyweight you're talking
night and day because the
af the the big dudes who are athletic
are getting into different sports really
they're not [ __ ] punching the face
that makes sense and the smaller guy
doesn't have as many options and if they
want to go professional it's usually
fighting
and there's just more smaller people in
the world so the
samples you know the pool of 55 and
under is
stacked you know how good you have to be
do you rank the top 15
that's the thing when you look at that
you're like killer stud
killer stud one two fifteen it's a
nightmare and even
one through 50 in the world at 135 145
155
nightmare i have to tell you so goddamn
good i i
like watching heavyweight boxing but
honestly
hit me with the flyweights with them
throwing 9 000 punches yeah
if you if you like enjoy the the sweet
science of boxing if you watch a guy
like
lomachenko i mean you're talking but i
love that
you know what i really there's something
about watching francigano just
charge a guy like fred flintstone with
his hands down and knock him out in 15
seconds
there's something about that yeah i
think then obviously the knockouts and
the knockout power and the one punch
powers i think
a lot of times for me anyways when i'm
watching the bigger boys
i'm watching for that one because you
know like if that guy makes a mistake
this game's over
at any point in time that's what i i
think the if you have to watch one
like let's say aliens came this planet
and they're like who should who should
we watch and get
get the best takeaway to report back to
our planet who's the one guy
as far as technique uh technique
his style is everything put together if
we had to watch one guy who would you
watch i'd say style bender is he
yeah israel's honest i think without a
doubt for me when the guys get too big
it's it i don't wanna say boring but i
like the reason i like the flyweights
especially in boxing it's a thousand
punches it's action action action action
actually their technique because if
they're there their techniques fall
right and so i i really like i love
watching
lighter dudes just go at it but there's
something about somebody who is
man when george foreman beat what's his
name michael moore sure
he was waiting for one punch yeah the
entire fight
he was just like i'm not gonna out punch
this dude i'm waiting for one punt
yeah and i think too the more the ufc or
even in boxing too like you know there's
so many good fighters out there when you
know their story like when you hear
cheetos story come from ecuador you're
like jesus christ dude
and what people don't realize in ecuador
he's tom cruise
dude he has billboards everywhere he's
on kia commercials he
you know he's doing it he's literally he
can't walk around the town he'll get
bombarded like tom cruise i mean
he's like i come here and it's like i
need a few pictures but it's because we
know nothing shoots you to the top like
a kia commercial
yeah yeah well unless you're blake
griffin
yeah he's like griffin remember we dunk
over the kia yeah
yeah yeah yeah ecuador remember that's
all they have dude
that's it bro is he that dude from that
kia commercial dude is that the kia guy
in america if i was like if i was like
hey josh i got some
big rumbling you're like what's going on
like i shot a kia camaro phil you're
like
give up things are tough huh things are
tough things are tough
i do want to say man this particular
sandwich it's unreal
and and i haven't had bread in a long
time 15 years
probably not 15 years but i like to go
with 15. it's been i'll go 15. yeah
thanks dude yeah
it it's been a minute and uh this is so
good it's on real
it's unreal how are they going to feel
about me chewing in the microphone oh
you'll be fine it's that good
cat were they when you went there were
they like ah cat what's up show us your
feet
uh no they actually had to shut down
their location
for uh because of kovid i guess they had
like a kovitz here within their team
they opened up
yesterday and i had to have it delivered
to a location close to the store and
then i picked it up from there
that's so funny she's like everyone's
dying over here
it's delicious apparently the chef who's
real hands you got covered dude so they
shut it down but
i got the last two sandwiches like what
what heat is josh eating uh medium it's
okay the heat will kill off covet
that's true and then chin you ate it
your nose is right i had a medium but
i'm i'm still dying from it right now
not me did you try yours
yeah i had a hot when was it hot hot
it's pretty hot
but you're good with hot i'm pretty good
you like it spicy you like like i like
ghost pepper in my stuff
when my mouth goes numb i can't taste it
i don't get it you get used to it let me
tell you what i don't like but wait what
what's mine
uh there is one hot and one medium so
you can choose either you're welcome
i'm gonna go higher okay i'm gonna like
your spice i want medium
i see here's the reason i can't go too
hot it's not how it feels in my mouth
it's how it feels coming out of my ass
it's trouble yeah like
you know what i hate like when it goes
you know what it like it almost feels
like a like a hot razor blade coming out
it's lava out of your [ __ ] yeah it's
a nightmare and you know it's all day
you know it's coming and it's all day
yeah and you make this noise oh yeah
it's all day
it's all day yeah i don't like it but
this is
worth it and the bread i think is that i
will challenge anybody if you want to
put up your goddamn nashville chicken
hot sandwich against howland ray's
[ __ ] come at me bro i'm with you this
has nothing the guy has coveted big deal
i can taste it i had covered my cardio
is better
and i can wear this scarf now i did
match it today again bro
i like that you call it a scarf yeah i
know i refuse called a bandana
i'm just going to call it a kerchief
until you start taking them off
dude you did a show last night yeah i do
have one more question for you you know
it's
it's summer in los angeles and you're
wearing a beanie a beanie
a beanie eating spicy food and long
sleeves long sleeve
and a scarf what's happening fashion
does not care about your weather
fashion has no limit and there's no air
conditioning yeah man yeah i mean it is
toasty yeah and and you're eating a
spiced sandwich yeah
well i tossed some hot sauce on my
macaroni and cheese and i was sweating
so bad
what is your favorite thing
if you were gonna go mac and cheese with
so i had them i had a lobster mac and
cheese
that's nice at steakhouses a nice
lobster mac
nice do it really good how are you
with i don't need like when people are
like i got a gouda mac and cheese i'm
not gonna get the [ __ ] out stop it no
stop why are you [ __ ]
give me that old classic mac and cheese
dog yeah like
i don't need what i'm obsessed with
right now is uh i eat pretty clean at
home just depends if i'm stressed out i
don't
but i've been getting boiling crab have
you had oil it's like so
good i get but you're asian now dude
you're waiting for really
i think they're originally from new
orleans oh i didn't know that so i
ordered it probably
three four times a week they have the
bada bing shrimp
oh the whole shebang that's what i get
with the white rice yeah yeah that's
what i get i get this spicy spicy
yeah i love it i dip in cocktail sauce
my mouth is water right now and then i
get three pieces of corn it's dripping
wet with all the sauce
dude i deep throw that corn on the cob
there's nothing like your brother pat
did you say you deep-throated oh yeah i
was watching because my girl is in
chicago i got the kids alone so i put
them into bed
yeah i've had the kids how long she's
been there since sunday so i've had the
little baby in the in
and tiger solo and
i love it i actually i i love it i
absolutely love it
so what time are you getting up in the
morning i get up at five
give it five the baby wakes up at 6 30
but me and tiger up at five
and then you know do all the things i
can't bike ride you know when i got him
because i can't leave
right long and so let me ask you a
question did you ever
just add a pure curiosity when either of
the kids were breastfeeding did you ever
ever let them not latch onto a nipple no
i did it looks like it hurt
yeah it wasn't great they're like sucker
fish oh yeah yeah
and look at my son he has two teeth and
they're for especially for
yeah these teeth are like [ __ ] like a
hippo man he looks like a baby hippo
they latch on dude yeah i bet it hurts
dude it didn't feel great
but my kid's pushing away the milk my
not my nine month was like dude
have you ever tried sweet the milk it's
but it's also it tastes like [ __ ]
pennies
it tastes like pure [ __ ] mmm the the new
milk formula tastes like pure [ __ ] so i
can understand why i didn't like it so i
even i thought you were talking about
the milk coming out of the titties oh no
no
yeah sweet have you eaten you never
tasted today
you never tasted titty milk out of
curiosity sucked on tits never got milk
oh it's sweet man oh it's sweet well the
fork you know because my son's not
breastfeeding anymore so he's with
formula
and he would keep pushing it away i'm
like what is he doing so
let me try this like oh [ __ ] i get it it
tastes terrible it's
awful so i've just given real food
why do you think it's too old to
breastfeed
14. yeah i think so too i don't know
what it's weird right because i've seen
ever seen the moms where there's like a
nine-year-old it's on its tits like what
are you doing girl listen
someone has mental issues i'm guessing
it's not the nine years well the
nine-year-old is about to
you know what i don't want i don't want
a memory of me sucking my mom's tit
no i don't remember but also the mo also
the moms who do in public
they get like their tit out it's like
you put a shawl on well i don't mind it
if the baby i don't mind it in public
really no just a tit just a if the
baby's nine i mind it yeah but if the
baby's like
six months man at that point to me it's
not even a tit like
it's not sexualized at all do you know
what i mean i just
depend if the mom's super attractive i
feel weird about it you know
i think if you can like if you're old
enough to say i'm hungry mom
i don't want a sandwich how about some
titty
you're too old yeah it's a weird dynamic
if you're asking for a little bit of the
milk in your hot chocolate
yeah it is straight you're too old but
so you don't like to see that that's not
good for you you want a blanket over it
nope i take that back i don't mind it
yeah yeah i i i don't like stare at i'm
just like yeah all right
yeah to me like it it's not sexualized
at all
especially if kids at this time it's
like yeah she's trying to feed the
goddamn kids yeah man and you remember
your wife breastfeeding and just how
messy everything
like she's hot it's a bonus though like
no that's cool it's not terrible no
it's not the worst yeah but i look at
that the jim carrey is that was such a
funny scene
yeah it is a by the way i think that's
an underrated jim carrey movie
uh me myself and irene i think that's an
underrated dude jim carrey on marc
maron oh they talk about the commie
store and him coming up there
really oh it's so good it's pretty new
because it's via like zoom and and him
uh just get into everything man it's
fantastic
really it's so good mark's so good with
other comedians on his podcast
because he's not like how'd you get
started why'd you get started like he
really dives in he's my favorite
carrie jim carrey does or did
nobody's done that physical comedy
in so long yeah like i really like you
know greg garcia i was telling you about
him he
created my name as earl and raising hope
and yes dear and a bunch of other shows
and i asked him i go what's the
and his shows stay on the air and he
goes i really lean into
um i'm sweating i i lean into physical
comments do you even cut yourself
no i wrestle with my dog oh my god
i i'm stronger than my right than with
my left and you're just like giving it
up
well do you get all high and [ __ ] we
wrestle in the backyard
he's half pit half american bulldog
jesus christ he comes at me
he [ __ ] your arm up oh he [ __ ] me up
yesterday i thought you were cutting
dude no
no no no we we um he [ __ ] but he'll
he'll get
into his get into it i love it yeah i
love wrestling with him
he like he'll put his uh mouth around my
neck but real soft
like he's just that's cool yeah sprite
doesn't end well but that's not no
yeah i mean i'm i'm i'm my wife
yesterday was like yesterday uh
you really end up like siegfried yeah
yeah did you say
siegfried and roy would have been a
great one oh that was uh
nick schwartzen's uh he was kind of he
came in one day and started roasting me
and callum
and he goes yeah you look like sick
freaking roid
he called me italian lego so you look
like an italian lego
he's so [ __ ] funny he is ridiculous
he's so funny
him on stage you know what i love about
him and
guys like him and kevin hart is they
lean
into ridiculous stories yeah i love it
and they by the way callum does it too
yeah i love leaning into a story that is
so
obviously not true yeah but telling it
with such conviction
yeah i mean when i wat and i every time
i see
uh brian i do text him the next day like
i don't know he's a beast your
commitment
to the ridiculous yep is like that's why
he's fun
next level peter pan man yeah did you do
you see kevin hart they
uh they [ __ ] up because yeah he's
saying both
usain yeah and they posted a picture of
kevin hart
they said it was something wrong with
the machine they're like oh this just
the
it just miscalculated somebody got fired
for sure a hundred percent
but also come on dude obviously they
didn't mean to do that it's not they're
not racist
kevin hart's reaction was so funny so he
was like i'm taking a break step back
from comedy
yeah he no you know it's some of these
but that so kevin hart had fun fun fun
they saw like everyone's like this is
racism he's like
it is appalling come on kev i do think
like some of these things just have to
be chalked up as
people make mistakes i think so they're
not racist there's none
there's none of that i mean look i don't
know
i don't know the person who posted it
this seems like a
i would assume that somebody doesn't
want to lose their job
so you know what i mean someone just
made a simple mistake and you
listen hussein ball and uh kevin hart
two the most
famous people on the planet trust me no
one's like yeah this black guy do
they're not there's no way
you give that person there yeah you give
that person too much credit i agree it's
a silly mistake
they [ __ ] up i wouldn't want stuff to
be mad at
if they got i mean the truth of the
matter is also though it's nbc
it's nbc news like there's who who is
the person
who's overseeing that that's you know
what i mean like it is it's a huge thing
so they should probably be better at
their job but i agree with you
no one should get no fired over that a
hundred percent
getting fired over cut over too much see
i think the cancel culture and i think i
told you this i think cancel culture
itself
doesn't do what they're trying to do
they're making
it worse right because you're pushing me
back into my corner
you're you're you're you're making
another enemy
instead of instead of an ally yeah
instead of going hey here's the mistake
you made
let me just educate you a little bit on
on what you said
that wasn't right yep and that's the way
to do it like when we just start walking
around canceling each other
no one's ever gonna learn ever ever and
we might you're missing out on great
talent like see what you want about nick
cannon but you guys cancelling him and
now you know he's gone the complete
opposite way he's trying to educate
himself
more it's like that guy's a lot of
talent made a lot of tv
a lot of tv that you guys watched was
great on the radiohead the number one
radio
syndicate show in the nation on
especially in la like
you're not getting that anymore and for
what he made one
like horrible don't you wrong oral
mistake i don't stand by any of it
but if he came on there was a guy [ __ ]
up man i'm i'm and he talks about his
everyone no one in in especially america
loves anything more than a comeback
story
a guy who learned from a mistake and
comes back we all celebrate it
so you're gonna vote him off the island
dude i'm a jew
what he said did not make me think
get rid of this [ __ ] it made me
go he doesn't know
what he's yeah oh he's not as smart as i
thought no it's not even smart it's like
he he does it he's not as educated on
this
he has been told some stuff and he's
never done the research behind it
and yeah and that's laziness yeah on his
end yeah
because you can tell you obviously he's
a smart business dude and he's
great on radio and he's a smart funny
dude
i thought it you know he's created
weilin out like he's done a lot of great
stuff
and then when it comes to religion and
jews and stuff like that
dude come on what are you doing i think
religion and jews and stuff like that
should be a t-shirt
you know religion jews stuff like that
but
i agree with you man and and like
don't get me wrong some people should be
canceled like when they bring up
some tweet like old teeth and like oh
that's rough
ugh that's tough but i also think man
like it's not that they should
not be able to work ever again oh and
also i
i think you said some things when you
were 20 years old that you would never
say now
correct okay so we said some things two
weeks ago
yeah i said something this morning it
would never ever where i'm like ah what
the [ __ ]
but the thing we don't allow each other
to do anymore
is make a mistake no the thing that we
what is baffling to me
is when they take say a politician and
they go
the politician goes this is what i
believe in and then they pull something
up from 25 years ago and they go
gotcha you voted on this in 1974
he's all again 74 that i didn't know i'm
a different person
it was a different culture nobody was
for gay marriage or whatever that was
right
so to go gotcha on somebody from [ __ ]
it's so bananas to me that we have given
up
on allowing people to get to become
better people
like you you're not we're not allowing
them to go hey this is who you are well
you gotta be that [ __ ] person forever
unless you're a politician and like
in the last few months you've said some
[ __ ] where you're going the election
that's like oh well if you're
if you're 86 where the [ __ ] bite is and
you're that
now we can't vote for you you know like
when yeah when he was with charlotte and
he was like
if if you don't vote for me you ain't
black yeah and show me went
oh no i don't subscribe what yeah and
then now
obviously the republicans are bringing
it up they're they're
poking them on he's like i didn't mean
that's like yeah you did i mean here's
yeah he did
that's your job dude yeah dude the thing
is also is that like
when you talk and you know this when you
talk so much into a mic
you make a lot of mistakes it's bound to
happen
there is zero chance if you do this like
you and i do for a year
there's zero chance if everyone listens
to everything you say
you go a year unscathed no there's no
way there's no way
there's there's no way unless you're
like you know on abc or nbc news and
it's all
highly produced right but if you're just
fine from the hip like we do
it's like there's no production like it
do you're making a lot of mistakes
a lot of mistakes and so and but i think
that's why people tune in
yes a little bit it's like yeah well
because it's not produced and we're not
playing
i told you somebody asked me hey so when
do you and brendan plan out the show i'm
like
playing the show what we walk in and sit
down
yeah like that's the and so i think they
assume
[ __ ] yeah i think there's a there's
an assumption that it's produced or
planned out
but like i i don't understand the joy
that people take now in the gotcha it's
a
it's a loser mentality it is right yeah
it's just a
it's just a straight loser mentality
because because you
want what they had and you thought maybe
they got different opportunities that
you never had and
you're unhappy with your life so let's
take this person down
because then they're at our level it's
like all right dude all right
it's count it's so counterintuitive to
me like you
actually what i for me for people that
i'm like all right with that dude
or her i instead of trying to take him
down i'm like
what are they doing that i can learn
from
yep that to the to help me get to
more of where crab mentality also people
are [ __ ] dude
they're just [ __ ] because here's the
thing let's say you cancel anybody ellen
nick cannon your life still sucks dude
and i hate to tell you but
ellen and nick can be fine yeah i think
allen's doing all right yeah i think
ellen
yeah yeah wait so is nick can you tell
you next time
absolutely you know it's like yeah you
took your show away from but he's gonna
be fine
but and your life's still gonna suck and
then when you move on to the next person
you cancel that your life still sucks
but there's always you're not getting
any
collateral there's so much collateral
damage to the tear downs
so say you tear down ellen the
collateral damage is everybody
who is the crew and works
at ellen all of the people at the
network or with the production company
associated with this show
like so the teardown there's no the
ripple effect
but but if you're not in show business
or you don't have if you've never been
around
you have they don't think of that oh
we'll take ellen out there and they'll
just replace her nope
if you take down ellen that entire staff
hundreds of people probably
are all gone because the new person
comes in and they're not used they have
their own team
i'm gonna tell you them so i was on
chelsea for i don't know
i was on the an episode in the first
week the show was on and i was on the
very last episode
so everything in between i had to be
over
200 episodes right and i was
crushing it for a long time oh my god it
was really hard
it's so hard you guys are like well you
might know jimmy k you're probably too
young chelsea lately yeah
i know of her i am a little too young
for the show
do you know who the very first fighter
ever was on that show ever
you're looking at him yeah first and
only oh i remember
yeah dude so look
at you guys the one thing i will tell
you about her
and somebody people have said to me
before uh
she didn't seem like she was having fun
in the last years or whatever like that
um she felt
responsible for the people who worked
for everyone she was like i'm
responsible i remember i was like why
did i
talk to her once and she was like yeah i
may i may
stick around these extra couple years
i'm responsible for like a hundred
people's
jobs like she was very cognizant
of it's not just her and she did
basically what she could do and stayed
as long as she wanted to stay
but like the people at the top there
they are responsible
for a lot of people's livelihoods you're
a captain of the ship right
your ships only go as far as you know
the the the captain like chelsea or
jay leno or ellen and ellen or oprah
like that ship's going to go as far as
they can take it man
yeah man they're responsible for a lot
of people it's it's a lot of
a lot of that sure man you walk in every
day thinking
uh i want to get out of here but if i
leave tomorrow
all these people are unemployed but
tomorrow i'm going to be fine
yeah chelsea was special too maybe for a
talented lady
yeah man i listen i will tell you i
loved working for her
i know some people didn't but i like
working
with and for people who are just gonna
tell me what they think yeah
i don't need the they're saying that
yeah yeah you know one of the things
that like
when you go to casting right and read no
matter what
the casting director goes that was great
thanks a lot come on no matter what just
tell me
yeah i'm a [ __ ] grown-up but i don't
want to think about it in the car if i
haven't sucked yeah
just be like it's actually going to help
me move on if you told me it sucked
that's it and i'll get better from it
dude look you know one of the things
that i loved about my dad
is my dad wasn't hey you can do anything
that was just not his thing he was very
honest if you were trying something and
you weren't good at it he was like you
could still do it
i'm not going to tell you not to do it
but this isn't this isn't your thing
yeah thank you yeah like thank you
were you that way with your kids yeah
man yeah you're kidding like i want to
be president
look you know hey bubba jacob was like
early on
he was like man i'm i really want to
play football i'm like dude you are
5 11 120. it's a tough gig
maybe not for you no man he was because
he has great hands and speed
but i i was like you you're going to go
across the middle 5 10 120 you've seen
calvin johnson
yeah those are big dudes uh yeah the
thing i struggle with is my girl's
grandma passed away right
so my girl and her her mom my son's
grandma they dip out right away
and we just told my son tiger because he
knew what was going he's like what what
happened like remember that grandma he
saw in chicago she passed away
he's like passed away it's like yes
she's gone he's like gone you know he's
like you're on
it's like yeah she she died he's like
died like
that lizard in the backyard i'm like yes
that lizard's
never coming back you know because he
had this lizard
not a pet but just yeah we'd feed and he
like come around all the time then
we found the lizard i don't know just
you know the [ __ ] lizard dude he died
yeah yeah he's like what's wrong with
the lizard like lizard died dude
and i was like he but what's tough it's
like you know my son goes well
what happens to grandma now it's like uh
and
i'm not a real i don't believe in like
you know i'm not an atheist i believe in
a higher being but i don't
it's hard to describe to a kid you're
not saying she lives in heaven
that's not where you because that's not
what you believe but you know what i but
that my initial i go
she's in a better place now and it was
weird i'm like laguna beach
she's in palm beach florida buddy
i don't know you know so i struggled
because i went and she and then
because my i think my girl said heaven
he goes she's in heaven i go
oh and i was like where's your girl's
mexican yeah catholic catholic
and is she she's not no no are parents
practicing no
but they grew up super strict catholic
so they you know i think they just said
it because that's the thing to say yeah
oh grandma's in heaven now so am i
saying oh she's in heaven i'm like where
do i go with this
and i went she's in a better place buddy
mm-hmm you know
i i i so i think your energy goes
somewhere but i don't know where
dude so try describing that to a
four-year-old impossible
but i agree with you dude i'm i i'm not
a spiritual guy
but i believe in energy because you know
the basketball right now is the to me
if you don't believe in energy just
watch basketball right now
and listen to those guys talk about the
ener they feed off the crowd
they the energy they feel from all of
those people
when you walk into a stadium a home like
a football field
it's a home team and the game's going
well
you can feel the comedy club right you
can feel it so
you can feel it it's like you know those
bees
kill the other animals it's like that
that that
you can it's without a doubt and so
how would you quantitate that or how
would you describe that you know what
i'm saying like
a scientist came in it's like well
what's going on here like when you get
to the comedy store
if you do you know the helium or
wherever you know in portland and it's a
sold out crowd and you walk in
you just you can feel the vibration of
human
bodies like it's this weird negative
energy too but also dude like
negative energy too but also dude like
we've all been around getting people who
work at fives
give them five of them they have a
different there's something about them
there's a different energy there's an
aura there's
yeah there's this weird energy like oh
yeah and everybody listening you've been
in a room where someone's walked in
or what and you're like dark energy it
could be a dark or something but you can
kind of feel sort of heavy
i believe in energy dude and so i i've
had the conversation we
look i'm jewish beth is catholic uh
jacob went to uh uh temple israel for
preschool but we put him in notre dame
for high school sure because i wanted
i wanted him to take his he can choose
for his own like it's not up to me
what he's going to believe but when they
ask me what i believe
i believe what you'd believe which is
we're energy and when our
body leaves i think sometimes the energy
sticks around
that's that's just what i think we're
all i think that's yeah that's how i
feel it yeah i agree
that's how i try to describe that kid is
a nightmare do you believe in ghosts
i don't know it's not that i don't but i
don't know
do you think it more more because
rogan made a good point with post malone
he goes
ghosts won't just show up during scary
times when it's dark outside like we've
never seen a ghost on the beach
well you've never seen a ghost like you
know like in the club like why would
they just avoid clubs
i here's what you want to hear my theory
on that you know such a good point you
don't think there's a ghost in the club
no one's ever seen it there's no picture
it's always this spooky house like i
don't
only decide to stay in these creepy ass
areas i'll tell you and that's because
of movies right that's because that's
we associate it like movies paint such a
dramatic picture for everything
so it's like daylight i mean i think so
i think like why isn't a ghost at a
football game
because a comedy show i here's what i
think
first i think um harder to see the ghost
in daylight that's that's not a i don't
know
that yeah that looks like the bird [ __ ]
on the window like i don't know it's
true but i think harder to see ghost in
the daylight
but i also just believe man that
uh you believe it but like bad beings i
believe in bad and people
i bel i believe in bad and good i re i
really i cuz i believe in energy right
so i believe that sometimes bad energy
gets left behind i think it just all
stays
here on earth no sometimes i it goes
somewhere else
no when the energy's gone i think it's
gone oh wow so when you when
like well no then you don't believe in
ghosts dude i believe in
that so say you die man right yep and
but your energy
stays here did you just fart no i was
tapping on wood i thought you gave me
i don't want to die what's the what is
the word tapping on wood dude it's like
a good luck thing you don't want tap you
know
knock on wood knock on wood yeah yeah
but knock it but i tap the foot
yeah but but but what it does i don't
want to die okay i'm like if you die
driving home by the way i don't believe
it but just in case you know what i mean
like yeah
i don't even know if i believe that but
yeah but i believe that sometimes man
like
the energy stays and and until it's done
until it burns out that's why i think
ghosts end up
like stuck do this doing the same thing
yeah
because that's kind of what they're i'm
gonna tell you a story that you may or
may not believe
you're gonna tell me a ghost story right
now i'm gonna tell you one you may and i
may not believe it okay
all right now what be careful because i
was on ghost adventure with zach baggins
so i know my sheriff ghost okay okay all
all right i'm gonna tell you when you
may or may not play
and i for sure uh
i'm sure i'll get a couple of toasty
comments yep
yep i mean rightfully so though you know
yeah man and by the way i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah i mean what are you gonna do
so i did a show for facebook
this year called josh wolf's wonderful
world of weird i got a leech put on my
[ __ ]
i got oh dude it was a banana for
medical reasons
uh that's what they said but i just did
it for the show i ate
uh bull dick soup uh i i went all in
right
did you travel all over the world for
this or all in los angeles oh wow
all in los angeles well we went down to
this hotel in downtown l.a
and i believe in energy but i've never
really come across go so i've never
really experienced it
sure so we're in this hotel and um
one of the rooms they just can't
was just disheveled and they were like
well we'll send you up to this whatever
that room was
and and i go why this room they said
well we can't
rent it out because people always ask to
leave that room because weird [ __ ]
happens in it
so you walk in it's got upside down
furniture nobody's been in there and
but there's two separate rooms in this
hotel room so we walk into this one room
and it's
kind of chilly and i'm like huh i walk
in but nothing's happening we walk into
the other room it's noticeably warmer
i'm talking to the ghost expert he's
telling me [ __ ] and i don't know how
much i believe it you know i'm leaning
into the show a little bit just because
you're trying to get entertainment right
we walk back into the first room
and we're finishing up the the shoot for
that room
and we all hear some music and i'm like
you guys hear that music and there was a
little radio
like an old-timey radio that was playing
just this old country music
love it and it wasn't on by the way when
we walked in
on now so i'm like the crew's [ __ ]
with me yeah okay
and the guy the ghost guy goes he said
i think the guy in here likes music the
ghost is in here and i'm like yeah
whatever
and he and i said let's just so we can
finish up the shoot let me just unplug
it
so i unplug it now when i unplugged it
it
before it turned off it got louder which
is i'm like whatever maybe it's just an
old radio
and uh we finished up the shoot and the
guy says to me
hey plug it back in don't keep it
unplugged for this guy
he likes he goes like he likes music i
plug it back in
different station so different music not
country anymore
and louder interesting just plugging it
in plugging it out
radio turning on by itself now i was
like wha
i'm the first one with the radio being
on
i didn't have eyes on it yeah [ __ ]
happened i'm still i'm the one who
unplugged and plugged the radio
that is weird and so i it's one of those
things that's
when something is not i can't explain it
yeah you can't chalk it up dude it's
hard for me do you hear about that one
lady downtown oh yeah i already know
you're talking about
do you know what i mean you know what
i'm talking about what are you talking
about yeah the water tank the water
tanks
the creepiest one of the creepiest
that's that's the creepiness story in
l.a
it's a is a hotelier channel stressed
out it was a hotel
downtown l.a and she went missing they
have her on the elevator
terrified terrified she goes missing
they find her
in a water tank but this water tank they
had detectives and investigators
like there's no way into this there's no
there's no way to get into this water
how the [ __ ] did she die i mean there's
no way
into there's no like you would there's
this the way the water tank works it's
not like
she could climb in and dr like there's
no there's no
logic yeah so she they have first of
a surveillance video elisa lam
yeah she was bizarre so they there's
she's just terrified here
and then she then they're scared of
something terrified
look at her pressing all the buttons on
that one road down
and the elevator door doesn't want to
close either
and then just watch watch her and you
freak out why is she pressing all of
those buttons no one knows
but she keeps looking like you know like
something's chasing her yeah
and she's like oh [ __ ] oh yeah that look
out the door right there dude is eight
year old
she's hiding for some look at her what
the [ __ ] man
and they never solved this nope nope so
they never water tower
inside the watchtower that they can't
figure out how a human could get into it
they're saying it's too heavy for her to
to like open it and how come
how big is this like is it like like
like one of those old-timey things that
they used to keep the water in for yeah
it's an old building cecilia cecilia
hotel you know and
it it took like a machine to pry it open
and look in there and why isn't the
associator moving yet
i know that's what's creepy and then she
just does this weird stuff
and so there's no video from when she
gets out of the
elevator that is i mean i don't think so
but
crazy that weird yeah man
her hands up or now do you know what i
think i think about all the time
is and i know this sounds weird you know
how easy it must have been
to get away with crimes before cameras
the easiest do you know what i mean like
if you get caught as a criminal
before cameras you're the worst the
worst the [ __ ] worst
criminal because just drive to the next
town man ain't nobody know who the [ __ ]
you are
no idea man there's i did i wrote um
a script me and my friend jonathan check
wrote a script
uh that adam sandler's company bought a
couple years ago
a truce b madison yeah a true story a
guy named rick dempsey who played
he was a catcher for the orioles and the
dodgers
um but he uh told us a story about a
real story about
a um all-star team out in canoga park in
the 60s i think like 1963
something like that and this all-star
team i think
seven of the kids think about this dude
seven of the kids on this one all-star
team went on to play
some level of professional baseball damn
do you know
i mean you know that's to have one is
crazy but this team had rick dempsey it
had robin yount who's in the hall of
fame and had
his brother larry so it has monsters
the coach on this team you used
the team as cover because it was a
traveling all-star team
to rob a bank in every town he went to
oh wow
and so he he could just go to the field
it wasn't like there was a phone look
out for this dude no
indeed no idea short stops caught
stealing that's what it is
the shortstop's dad was the lead
detective
for the case oh wow so he would come to
the practice
and the coach would ask him and he and
he breaks and he's like no we can't find
these guys
they were the mutton jeff robbers but
because they could
if you were in studio city you could rob
a bank in studio city and just drive to
burbank it's not like they had a picture
no they have nothing do you know what i
mean so to get caught as a criminal you
think as a detective
if the the away team's playing in
cleveland
baltimore yeah you know florida
albuquerque and there's bank
robberies and all those the detectives
like weird my sons
i think it was figured out i think it
was mostly california but i still you
know right
this is where we were just playing there
but it was such a crazy story man
have you ever looked i don't mean an
interrupt have you ever looked at how
much
bank robbers actually get when they rob
a bank now it's
like three thousand dollars get the [ __ ]
out of it yeah people think it's like
crazy money but
they're only getting away with i think
two to three thousand dollars not worth
it
because i bet you you could get that
much from like a coin shop or a pawn
shop
why are you going to do a bank in 2006
the average bank robbery netted about 4
300. that's
terrible find a good average of 1500 for
all commercial robberies what you should
know before robbing a bank
good thing u.s news wrote that article
the average take out of 7-eleven 760
not worth it what's worth it for you
what's worth
what's worth the risk of going to jail
and possibly getting shot
so you gotta these people are probably
pretty desperate but what's worth it is
it
seven hundred dollars that's not what
rob was seven eleven that's not worth it
that's gonna get you how far no and most
of it's in quarters
like i mean you don't what do you you
don't want that [ __ ] like a nightmare
they it seems though like they used to
and i wonder
if they used to get more out of the bank
like
in the movies in the old movies you're
thinking they're like rob won they're
sad
yeah i mean i don't think it's ever been
that way hasn't we just again
movies painted a picture right that
they're they rob one bank they're right
after the sunset right and they
they had a safe full of just cash it's
not that way
i would be a terrible bank robber i
don't think if i was gonna commit a
cr like a major crime i don't think
bank robbing is my would be my mine
would have to be some kind of
feeling like high-end art no it would be
some kind of shyster
like i would be conning people like i
think if i was gonna commit a crime
i would ponzi scheme ah maybe or just
like
you know maybe like a lonely 65 year old
woman who's just looking for something
to hang out with
you're looking for a sugar mama yeah
something might be like
then your name would be like josh the
widowmaker um
and then you're just going from like old
cougar cougar taking money
if i was going to i think that's the
only thing i'd be good at
i'm not a real physically intimidating
dude i see i think we would do something
like
ocean's eleven like a big one oh yeah
dude that'd be cool
but in ocean's eleven years what role
are you in ocean's eleven
like who i think everyone wants to be
george clooney but i think i'd be more
of
don cheadle well no you know what i if
let's let's go more with the italian job
okay i think i'd be
probably most deaf the deaf guy's just
blown [ __ ] up
um i i want to be in the italian job
i'm i'm mark wahlberg you want to be
mark yeah i think so i think so
in ocean's 11 i think brad pitt i like
the fact that he eats in every scene
he's in
i love that part too i don't know i
don't know why but my man gets to eat in
every
scene and it's delicious rick and morty
did the do you watch ricky morty yeah
they did a hilarious
uh one of it the heist one where rick
and mort
rick oh my god it's so funny and they
copy ocean's level with the music
yo you son of a [ __ ] i'm mad yeah i'm
gonna go home yeah i'll be my son
because he that's
his favorite always eating dude why
i i don't know but man he makes me
hungry whenever i watch him in a movie
he is i might be the old guy that they
go to oh
yeah yeah with the big glasses
yeah dude i can see you rocking the
glasses in the robe
i don't want to get my hands dirty but
i'll be behind it are you if i'm going
robe
i'm definitely going to ask scott i
don't i don't like uh robes do you
i don't have one i don't either i know
people who go to hotels and they lounge
in the robe i'm like
i only do have the hotel emma because
they have nice robes it's like
form-fitting it feels nice
but i don't like being all free and like
hanging with my [ __ ] legs now i see
your question
do you think they wash those robes yes
you tell them i do now the hilton
probably not yeah because
i know for sure the reason i don't put
them on is somebody's naked [ __ ]
when they sit down see i don't mind it
even with covert days i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't
i'm not even talking about covet i just
don't i don't need naked [ __ ] on my
back i'm not too worried about it dude
no you ever seen like the versace
like the gucci ropes those like dope
those do
i i i i don't know why you're so
casually okay with naked [ __ ] like
i don't either no i don't care dude but
you don't know what that
you don't know where that [ __ ] see i
can't matching me my girl chilling like
just two [ __ ] matching robes beth
and i woke up the other day
and we were in nashville and we both put
on uh a different form of camo pants
and i told her i go you gotta take you
take those yeah i don't like matching
like me my girl if some shoes are the
same if we both go downstairs online
she's like you don't want to match me
like no
no no there's the biggest [ __ ] i like
matching with my son
that's cute but when the husband and
wife match god
you know you know to me what's worse
than matching husband and wife
working out together at the gym husband
and wife that's not cool either
especially it's a crossfit oh dude there
was this husband and wife that used to
work out together that used to high-five
each other after every set
and i was like hey er you know everybody
hates you right like you shake the grind
i just yeah but when they match like
that oh i also don't like when parents
met or if there's twins
and they dress them the same i don't
like that up to age four
i'll give them cute when they're yeah
i'll say i i give you age two after two
you gotta quit dressing you get those
little two-year-olds and overalls
together
come on yeah they're cute they are so
damn cute
and i'll tell you something right now uh
twin
asian babies are like ridiculous oh
my [ __ ] god it is so
crazy but i i the the thing about the
robe for me man
and i'm with you is i i wear
a tighter underwear i don't like a boxer
i only wear tight undies because i like
it
i don't like the bouncing i don't know i
like can you sleep naked or do you no no
i'm not a guy who's it's not that i'm
not comfortable i just don't i don't
know
i mean i do i'm comfortable naked but
it's not like i just i feel
if i see megan i feel like i lost
something i
always feel like i'm missing something
like something's missing
i don't know why i can't really fear
that i'm gonna crush my nuts
i i don't i'm just not i just can't get
cozy naked no
you sleep naked cat yeah i can't sleep
with clothes on but they see there's one
or two people
yeah either you're butt naked or but i
think
i'm not bundled with me i'm in my undies
i think women are more comfortable
sleeping
more i know more women who sleep naked
oh not me
you i don't know a dude that sleeps butt
naked do you know a guy
it's just like it there's something
about the flop and i don't know a lot of
i don't know a lot of people in general
sleep naked you sleep butt naked cat
yeah
i can't i can take a nap for maybe an
hour with clothes on but if
it's anything longer than that i
naturally wake up i can't get
comfortable
even like in the winter kid yeah even as
a kid in the winter
in the winter are you from here yes oh
so you
might did you what's your my girl sleeps
in like a sweat suit i'm like
jesus christ man bro just sweat socks on
like a hoodie like do you not want to
see my dick
what are you doing you trying to lose
weight like where's
the phone for god's sake beth wears
panties and one of my t-shirts every
night
that's sexy as [ __ ] it is that'll do it
it's so good
my girl comes in like the goddamn salt
lake city olympics
winter olympics every night she got bad
circulation like
this dictionary's [ __ ] not
circulating getting ready for the
bobsled
earmuffs on july yeah
man getting jerked off with mittens
would be terrible no i don't want it are
you sleeping what chin
i have to have a shirt on too so i'll
show you shirt
boxers and a real comfortable shirt yeah
what's your girl sleep in
she'll actually naked that's why i
understand a lot of girls like to sleep
naked
she sleeps naked naked buck naked that
would be cool too
yeah i wouldn't mind if my if my girl
does it yeah a hundred percent
but i i don't there's a bunch of things
oh yeah i just got you tell them to come
in can we pause for sanchez
i can't follow i did i walk i walked
around times square naked for a little
while
how was that naked wasn't bad barefoot
in times square was alarming
that was the grossest thing i think i've
ever done i don't like being barefoot
either
not in times square i don't like being
on the beach i don't like see i don't
like
i'm not a barefoot dude either at all i
wish i was
they the barefoot people look like
they're having a good life barefoot
barefoot like people who walk around
barefoot look like
they're really enjoying their life i
can't even wear sandals in public
so lazy but i'm so lazy i don't think
dudes should be wearing
sandals
there is not a guy anybody who's like
well i take care of my feet
but i don't give a [ __ ] if we're at a
restaurant you get your bare feet out
oh thank you no [ __ ] way what
third world country did you come from no
you think it's all right
to be out in public with your bare feet
hey man and when i
i know it's sunday morning but i don't
need to see you
in your cut-off sweats with no underwear
and and flip-flops
[Applause]
oh i'm sorry is it [ __ ] hawaiian
friday shirt after office
why are you dressed like that dude
brendan there was a guy
last year on a flight people are getting
too [ __ ] comfortable on planes
clipping his toenails
clipping his [ __ ] i was just on plane
say same thing guy was clipping the the
the the [ __ ]
like uh extra skin off off the bottom
well you can bring a toenail clipper
no idea how you got it that's another
thing first of all how did you get that
on the plane
second of all what makes you think this
is okay you know what the guy told me he
goes uh
yeah i know but all the they're just
falling on the ground and i was like
first of all no
you said something dude yes oh i say
nothing oh
i judge from afar and i'm like damn
that's crazy
no no i would i had i we were sitting up
in front
and so i was against the window and
there was a dude in the aisle and in the
same row but
right across the aisle he was clipping
his nails so i turned the dude who's in
the aisle
and i go you gonna say something and he
goes nah man he paid for that seat i go
yeah i paid for this one
yeah i don't want to see him clipping
his hole good for you man so i just
leaned over i go hey man
you can't you can't clip your toenails
on the plane and he goes i'm just
trimming him up i go i don't
just change chair dude i'm just tripping
but also a little bit of a rebel but no
that there's not a rebel that's somebody
who doesn't is he a hell's angel [ __ ]
about
anybody else no i know he's an [ __ ]
yeah dude you know i loved it because
i've been flying during corona doing the
road gigs and stuff
my favorite is to watch people argue
about math
it's intense it's so funny it's intense
they argue about mass
it's not that people do it they argue
over the wrong math yeah it's intense
you know the mask with like the [ __ ]
weird like
the bane masks yeah yeah they came out
said those don't work those actually
spread it
because it you're just wearing this but
it's going it's shooting out the side
figure it out but so this uh lady was
arguing with the guy about it i love it
it it's so you guys think this [ __ ]
handkerchief is [ __ ]
the best way to do this dude this is a
thing like
we're in the we're we're trusting that
the flight attendants
no the flight attendant was like let me
tell you what i know i'm like
you what everyone's vouching now every
single day i felt
you know i've got to wear it on the
plane now they mandate yeah
but i fell asleep it came down i'm in a
deep sleep and i need to sleep
they wake me up sir you got to put your
mask on like oh you dick
i do something about the antibodies
right dick
somebody get kicked off my flight really
yeah yeah
see that family got kicked off because
the two-year-old wouldn't wear it mother
of six
no two-year-old she's two so he's like
i'm not wearing it
jetblue kicked him off the flight how
are you going to keep a mask on a
two-year-old anyways
but also no it's almost impossible
it's almost impossible to make a
two-year-old look you can't get a
two-year-old not to [ __ ] his pants do
you think he's going to keep a mask for
a four-hour flight
zero percent chance yeah zero percent
chance i i
i don't there's got to be count we've
lost common sense
in general like there's no we've decided
that common sense doesn't work
because a two-year-old clearly should
not have to or be
able to follow the same rules that are
it's insane grown-up it's insane
yeah i'm with you dude let's go some
current event all righty
okay so this is an update to uh
the whole kevin durant burner account
situation
on a podcast last week he said that he
was really upset with himself that he
let
people making fun of him about his
burner accounts get him to delete it so
he made another one
so he had openly admitted to having a
burner twitter
as well as a couple other social media
burner accounts
he said the reason why he got it again
was that he
is a part of different communities on
his burner page
and so he says that that was his
happiness and his joy
so he got his brother accounts back
these guys they're too into
social media dude like uh paul george
for the clippers he's been playing like
dog [ __ ] last game went off
finally because he said he's had
depression like in the bubble
and then he's been playing bad so he he
disengaged comments on his instagram
which the trolls are just like
what yeah got to him so they're just
waiting for him to open those comments
they're just
waiting that's like dude you're paul
george your top 10 player in the league
who gives a
[ __ ] dude you're listening to people
who on their best day aren't
one one millionth of the athlete you are
do you know what i mean like to take
criticism from a group of people
who in their wildest dreams couldn't do
what you
do but while you're making a run for a
world championship why are you on social
media reading comments but i disagree
with you about this guy
listen i i think you don't like kevin
durant i love him i
don't like when he went to the where's
stuff
look you do what you think is best for
you
and at the end of the day is that what i
think i would have done
i don't think so but i'm not kevin
durant i want to stay in oklahoma city i
know that
so if you want to go there and get paid
you know a ton of money and be mvp of
the finals yeah
also he's seven foot and can dribble
conduct a unicorn threes unicorn uh dude
to me he's the most downplaying league
i i i love his game he's on fire there's
nothing better
i just hate that i hate this the slim
reaper bro i hate this part of him
i think he's soft i think he's mentally
have you seen the way he goes at people
though
it's hilarious from his burn account yes
he was like you
punk out to a 13 year old bernard [ __ ]
who is
a punk ass [ __ ] who's got a burner you
can't do it from his way why not
well he's sponsored by nike yeah you
can't have that that's true all right
you have your signature shoe with nike
we can't have that okay
but it's a 13 year old he's like you
punk ass [ __ ] if i see you on the court
i'm putting my nuts in your face i'm
like that was the mvp of the finals two
years ago
yeah why are you talking [ __ ] to a 13
year old dude that's what
i mean man look man i respect the hell
out of you but uh
give me one legitimate reason for
leaving okc other than getting a
championship
he didn't like the organization or
playing for billy dom and his roster
wasn't that good it was just him and
russ
oh and he thought he was tweeting from
his burner yeah
do you ever see skip bayless i know who
skipped gayle bayless is i've never seen
his oh dude he had a true because
you know he just gets [ __ ] on social
media because he had he had yeah well he
has hot tapes right and that's what he
does and that's like you would tune in
so he had a party at a burner account
and you know someone said something he's
like i think skip bears is the best in
the business man keep
keep your head up man you're killing it
out there good luck man everybody should
tune in but he did it from his original
uh
skip you're the man
do you think he typed this up himself or
he has like
like someone who made it or you know you
could be somebody because it could be
like being instructed someone should do
it from over
to seven exclamation points
dude so if you let it social media each
other would that have been everybody
skip you the man love the new show on
fs1 great dick yeah you got a huge hug
ruber has it oh god it's so
these guys that do this man it's so
ridiculous so for me man
i'm with you that kevin durant may be
the most talented if not he's number two
or three
wherever you put lebron kawhi him right
i
think this is weak yeah
i i just think mentally he shows cracks
um when it comes to this stuff that he
doesn't need to show yeah i think he's a
little uh
a little emo with things maybe he might
suffer from some depression
this stuff gets to him do you do you buy
into the fact
or the idea when you hear some people go
well they couldn't have played in the
80s
because to me they would adapt they
would adapt right there's nobody in the
80s who could guard kevin durant
one-on-one
there's hand check or not nobody right
you don't think he would adapt he's a
seven
he has more skill than anybody from the
80s a seven footer
without without a doubt but it's also
just you know the like
the next generation is more skilled more
skilled more skilled they might have
been tougher back then he would adapt
he's a [ __ ] i i agree with you
man all those guys would adapt when i
hear people it's just steph curry
couldn't do the 80s i'm like look out of
here he would
he would have got dinged up and he might
not have played as long because he would
have got hit harder
but he did those guys those guys would
adapt you know what i'm saying like this
guy's going to dab yeah
but these guys are soft now because
that's the league's letting it get soft
so those guys are only playing with the
boundaries that the league set
okay so if you go the opposite like man
i love
charles oakley and anthony mason i love
those
the hard-nosed i love [ __ ] with this
yeah yeah but they would [ __ ] you is
there a place in today's nba
for guys like oak and mace we have is
like a draymond green a little bit but
he's still
not but the league doesn't let you do it
right he got rid of it they didn't want
that look anymore
do you like do you have a preference
over what type of game i wish
i liked the today's game i do wish there
was a little more physicality a lot more
i don't like as many fouls and stuff
like that yeah i i wish you were allowed
because i don't i think a hard foul as
long as it's legit
i think a heart and you're not throwing
someone to the ground but
you know when they say you have to make
a play for the ball look i don't want to
be easy too
what's interesting too with the the nba
some of the talk going on is like
you know they want equality and
obviously black lives matter
that you know that's their message right
now and guys are really harping on it's
good man it's definitely a change that
we need
but then with the you see what happened
with luca did we talk about this with
luka where the guy goes
you're a [ __ ] ass white boy you shut up
you [ __ ] ass white i didn't see that
yeah so this this black guy
for the clippers i think yeah clippers
oh on the clippers team yeah it goes
because uh luca looked and was quit
flopping you know shut
oh [ __ ] ass up white boy yeah now
luca just was like whatever kept on but
the mic picked that up
so there's been this you know the
canceled culture and other people like
well and yeah aren't you gonna do
anything about that because if luca
would have said
you [ __ ] ass yeah black boy or you
[ __ ] ass chinese guy if it's jeremy lin
or
if there's a mexican you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's mexican mexican guy in the
nba are you talking about there's no
there's not
you know what i'm saying like if you put
any other race there that doesn't get
suspended yeah
now if it's a black guy who said you
[ __ ] ass black boy he's probably never
playing again
with luca being white they were like
yeah he just said [ __ ] ass white boy
it is a derogatory term but also let me
ask you a question i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah let them go yeah because you know
what happened
they didn't penalize them they don't i
don't think you should be penalized i
don't think they should do anything
but you know it's weird when you ask for
equality but then it's only one way
and then you look at what they're doing
with china so it gets super messy there
which ruins their message but my thing
is is
luca went do you see the way he paid him
back hit the game winner yeah
went for 40 something points at the game
women won the game so like that's
payback like that's
that's sports if those guys want to talk
that [ __ ] they should be allowed to talk
that [ __ ]
i agree i i don't don't control like the
[ __ ] talking even if it's racial let me
just let them figure out on the court
is there a word that somebody could call
you that refers to you being white that
would offend you
nothing there's not even if someone was
like just different
yeah there's just it's just isn't a word
you go through the same
tribulations and you know horrible times
it's just different there isn't
a white boy call me a cracker it doesn't
matter you're delicious
yeah dude when i was playing uh
university of miami i remember every
time
they're all black there's like one white
guy and i remember every time i touched
people don't [ __ ] touch me white boy
don't call me don't touch me white boy
get the [ __ ] out of her cracker i was
like how long are we gonna do this what
position you play
full back like hvac i was on a special
team so i dealt with him a lot so it was
like
every time i touch him like don't
[ __ ] touch me right but i'm like dude
we got four quarters
yeah i'm gonna be touching you this is
the game dude yeah but also you know
where the term cracker comes from
uh i don't from the slave owners that
with the belt with the whip they crack
it so they called the white
masters crackers oh i i do have to ask a
question which is you you played high
level football i've always wanted to ask
somebody this
how come football players don't wear
cups like some do
i never did how are you
it's where you get hit there i remember
again same game miami dude
i wasn't wearing a cup his cleat i mean
i'm talking just
crushed my nuts but every baseball
player
wears a cup and the football player's
done that is
really get hit there a lot dude really
yeah and does anybody
are there you know the the the talking
about how in those in those piles people
punch each other and grab those oil
checks
yeah is that true oh yeah really oh yeah
so you
people get down and dirty finger in the
eye that kind of [ __ ] in the nfl level
it gets a little dicey but in general no
but in college yeah
you know so people are going for a ball
in the giant you'll see guys like
shitty guys like dominic sue like you
know grab a guy's ankle
yeah [ __ ] with it you know but in
general they're professionals man dude
and dominican sue you know i used to
travel cable guy i told you that and
he's a huge huskers fan that's right and
he brought me on the
sidelines to watch the huskers play
first i i guess when you get down on the
sidelines
because i only really watch football on
tv i
i had never appreciated just how fast
the speed of that game nuts but to watch
and dominic and sue
dominate and they were good then too
dude he was picking
other collet other men up under their
pads
and move just [ __ ] six four 300 pounds
and quick nuts moving people yeah
he but this dude i yeah we saw him twist
that ankle and
yeah he's done some pretty yeah he has
some anger issues he's
a couple anger issues what else you guys
got
so we talked about the kevin hart thing
already this is an update to the bella
thorne thing
um now that her only fan is live she has
made
one million dollars in 24 hours and
within a week she made two million
dollars jesus christ
she also says that she is not opposed to
posting
like kind of scantily clad photos of
herself
in her bra or like pictures of her butt
but her only fans
is just behind the scenes footage of her
in her day-to-day that's it
no nudes wow oh there's going to be
another she did it because someone was
going to
release her nudes she was like oh cool
story i'm starting now i think that's an
old uh
old story somebody threatened to release
her nudes and she released it herself
how many people tell me what percentage
of people as soon as she said i'm not
doing nudity just decided not to pay for
the second month my god god damn yeah
they were
yeah yeah she still got two mil though
yeah but 85
of those dudes were like what like
behind the scenes no she really
shouldn't have said that nah man i don't
want to see a makeup tutorial
teasing them man next next month you're
going to see a nipple
hilarious my son if there was a tease
for a nipple 100
he'd be paying 20 cents on the just
chance
of a nipple i mean whatever what else
you guys got
your boy your inkmaster artist oh daniel
silva
there's an update on him uh do you know
how much time he's getting a year
yeah what do you do got drunk
in his mclaren and uh killed his buddy
his buddy was his birthday i think and
they drove together the buddy was in the
past
this tattoo and then he was gonna do
this thick boy tattoo on my
thigh literally the day he
you know yeah [ __ ] up that the next
morning i supposed to see him i still
text him like hey man shitty deals
so 2 p.m or is that out before you go
away
you know you need time you can squeeze
me in
or before you go away for a long time do
you want to commitments commitment where
i come from
well listen i'm sure he'll be giving
tattoos in jail i mean they do
he'll be fine in there but you know he
had a year you know could have gotten
life he could have done
something really really bad listen he
shouldn't go away for a year he'll learn
his lesson he's
what 23 was he [ __ ] up yeah they're
both
but they're at a party both drunk so
here's my thing if we're both hammered
yep
and i go hey dude let's go for a drive
and you go cool you know i've been
drinking
i know you've been drinking we get in my
car
i mean you're you know you know what you
sign up for i know i'm signing up for it
we crash you know it's like that's
we all take the risk yeah man it's a
shitty move
you still there has to be some kind of
penalty i'm not saying he is
using a year of his life yeah i mean and
i'm sure he's been paying
serious money to that family that's what
i'm sure will end up coming down there's
got to be some sort of
because if that's my even if that's i
know my son got in that car drunk
i'm still i know i'm gonna be pissed
either way dude i'm i need more
oh this this is the thing that happened
in the
i got a story to tell you i can't tell
it on he's a great artist too man
i'm a nominal artist what's who i'm
gonna tell you something after
okay uh the you because
okay okay yeah one more one more
uh just this one it's interesting that
the comedy central
they renewed tosh porno for four more
seasons and then they
took it back i wonder why they said
they're going towards the uh
animation stuff and let me just say
before anybody else does
i've been called trailer park tosh
crackhead tosh old man tosh
i get it i get it i get it this dude
his show was so different
when it first and he delivered dark
comedy and he delivers it
in such with that boyish face that a
different not a dark delivery
like so it made it so much more
palatable the way he did it
i i think the way he he's a pioneer you
don't see
like when he comes on stage with that
face and the way he talks it's not jesus
it's so funny
you expect that out of jesus nick but
when tash comes out you're like i didn't
expect
that out of his and he's it sounds like
you they're taking the show to another
network though because he goes
this is his response he's actually funny
yeah he goes i look forward to doing an
animated
reboot on my show on mtv in 25 years he
goes uh after 12 years together comedy
central and i are
uh consciously uncoupling uh they get
cartoons and i'm head to any network
i mean there's some when you watch that
show
whether i never like him or not i always
watch that show guaranteed
guarantee laughs did you ever get to do
drunk history i never did it did you
no i wanted to do it uh and then it but
drunk history also was another
revolutionary
great show made me laugh all the time
and i haven't seen aquafina yet but i
heard that's really fun yeah i like her
have you seen the show i haven't seen it
i don't really like it
is that it dudes that's it by the way
that sandwich
topknot yeah i told you i'm a huge fan
of pickles and coleslaw on my sandwich
so we went we checked all the boxes
i'm pretty excited so good i'm gonna i
will let you know
what it feels like how it goes yeah
coming out but i think
i mean i haven't had bread in so long i
have a feeling it's just gonna you might
feel good yeah dude welcome to the bread
bread truck yeah i'm ready dude
full bread you're welcome
yeah i'm ready i'm ready we love you man
thank you
we're out